[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal einen
blechkuchen und zwar einen mit früchten
total frisch trotzdem so ein bisschen
orientalisch angehaucht weil ich da eine
richtig tolle zutat rein gebe das
verrate ich aber gleich ist natürlich
dran bleiben wir machen jetzt
zuallererst den boden und dafür habe ich
jetzt hier die küchenmaschine bereit
wenn ihr keine habt in dem betreuer
handrührgerät wichtig ist halt dass wir
wirklich die eier dich jetzt schon mal
rein gebe komplett hält cremig schlagen
für die eier sind drin und da gebe ich
jetzt auch noch zucker mit wein das
hilft dass die masse eben noch besser
herr klee mich geschlagen wird und dann
dauert das in der maschine so ungefähr
vier minuten mit der hart also mit dem
handrührgerät wird so sechs sieben
minuten dauern
[Musik]
für die eier sind jetzt hell cremig ich
habe auch schon mal männer dazu gegeben
und jetzt nehme ich einmal den schnee
bieten ab damit sich in aller ruhe meine
trockenen zutaten dazu sieben kann
wir brauchen mehl und backpulver und das
habe ich vorab schon miteinander
vermengt sodann verbindet sich das
einfach besser und jetzt einfach dazu
sieben und dann nur noch ganz kurz unter
rühren also wirklich nur ein paar
sekunden dass es sich gerade so
verbindet
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier mein backfisch
vorbereitet mit meinem neuen back ramon
drauf den habe ich jetzt eingestellt ich
werde euch die ganz genau maß angabe
hier unten in die video beschreibung
schreiben und da gebe ich jetzt den teig
rein und er wird ihn glatt streichen und
anschließend verteilen wir mandeln
obendrauf genau jeder ist echt toll weil
er absolut nicht mehr verrutschen kann
gut bei dem teig würde eh nicht
verrutschen aber wenn ihr mal hefeteig
macht dann geht er auf im ofen und
bleibt alles licht das ding
[Musik]
so und jetzt packen wir den boden im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für circa 20 minuten und
danach vollständig auskühlen lassen und
dabei die oberfläche mit einem sauberen
geschirrtuch abdecken
[Musik]
so in der zwischenzeit machen wir die
creme und dafür habe ich hier kalte
schlagsahne wichtig ist jetzt dass alle
zutaten kalt sind die habe ich hier
schon mal in meiner rührschüssel da gebe
ich jetzt noch quark dazu ich wollte
echt so eine locker leichte frühlings
sommer torte beziehungsweise blechkuchen
deswegen nämlich jetzt auf jeden fall
quark einmal mit da rein dann süßen wir
das ganze mit puderzucker und
aromatisieren nase und jetzt kommen
moment ich rede schneller als ich handle
ich muss kurz zu ende so moment
puderzucker rein weil mir extra groß ist
der klassiker und jetzt leute jetzt
kommt jetzt kommt geheime geheimzahl
orangenblüten wasser jetzt denkt ihr
euch allerdings noch nicht gehen wonach
schmeckt das nach orangen haben sie
schmeckt er orangen gar nicht gar nicht
ihr müsst es einfach mal ins gericht
das riecht so genial schon mal kurz zum
löffel raus haben sich meine spieler
nicht aufgeräumt so wie jetzt gebe ich
da maximal zwei esslöffel rein ich
meinen teil hab nämlich den kuchen
netzes ausprobiert und anderthalb jahren
perfekt
das macht jetzt orientalisch einfach
unterwegs silber einmalig so einen
teppich kein den halben noch dazu
und jetzt einmal rühren und dann planen
fest einrieseln lassen bis das total
steif ist und das funktioniert wirklich
wenn alle zutaten kalt sind doch alle
eigenen stücke könnten
ich hätte da sind nummer ich habe ich
dass wir haben jetzt fastentag nummer
vier
die heute schon gibt es ja ja ja gut ich
fange jetzt mal anlass alle fest ein reh
sehen nämlich wie die meiste dann steif
und alles ja alles nimmt dann noch nicht
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt noch frische früchte
fein geschnitten bei mir sind setzt
erdbeeren und himbeeren
wir können natürlich nehmen was ihr
möchtet tiefkühl früchte könntet ihr
nehmen rate ich jetzt aber nicht so weil
die verlieren er wasser und dann werden
sie so matschig oder weiß ich nicht also
ich hab jetzt frische früchte genommen
so und jetzt habe ich das untergräbt die
creme bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank das ist ganz wichtig und
wenn auch der boden ausgekühlt ist dann
vereinen wir alles miteinander
[Musik]
sobald der boden dann abgekühlt ist
einmal den bug raum befreien das macht
ihr am besten mit einem back vom loser
der durch auch nichts reicht an den
seiten und anschließend einmal mit dem
tollen schneider in der mitte
durchschneiden das funktioniert auch
wunderbar und dann haben wir ja einmal
das unterteil und die mandel decke und
die wände decke die müsst ihr vorab
einmal durchschneiden schon in der
rechte stücke ob wir das jetzt ganz
klein machen oder mittelgroße ist euch
überlassen ich mach das jetzt ganz
spontan
das müsst ihr aber vorab machen damit
ihr beim schneiden später die deckel
nicht in die creme drückt glaub mir
macht diesen schritt auf jeden fall
feuer
ich schnappe mir jetzt mein messer und
schneidet das jetzt einmal durch
[Musik]
so haben es fast geschafft um den boden
jetzt wieder den bug gramm legen ich
habe jetzt auch nicht saubergemacht dem
schritt spar ich mir einfach ich spare
mir das wo ich nur kann mal
geschirrspüler ist nicht so mein hobby
so und jetzt hab ich einfach nochmal
drum herum gelegt und dann die creme aus
dem kühlschrank holen und einfach glatt
verstreichen und die mandel decke
obendrüber verteilen das war's dann
hamburg super
[Musik]
diese quadrate darauf zu legen das ist
so ein tolles gefühl
das macht so richtig das ist so
satisfied euro so richtig na ja auf
jeden fall gebe es auch puderzucker und
drauf ich habe wir sind ein bisschen
durch die hungrig sind zufrieden so
werden etwa eine stunde bis die post
brechen
ich gebe jetzt butter zucker obendrauf
und eigentlich also liegt die creme
müsste eigentlich eine halbe stunde
kühlen dadurch dass sich die vorbereitet
habe und sogar schon im kühlschrank war
für eine halbe stunde könnte ist jetzt
prinzipiell sofort servieren
ihr könnt die torte natürlich bis zur
weiterverarbeitung einfach kühl stellen
und die hält sich auch so zwei tage
würde ich sagen
und jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel
freude beim nachbacken und hinterlässt
gerne ein bisschen nach oben schreibt
mir noch gerne was liebe es ich lese
immer total gerne von euch abonniert man
kann ein kostenlos aber das wisst ihr ja
schon was habe ich noch vergessen haben
sie in silber verlegen euch gerne auch
mal deine kaum
und genau die ganz genaue mengenangaben
stehen wie immer in der video
beschreibung hier unter dem titel und
dann sage ich bis zum nächsten mal auf
die gis kitchen jack's
[Musik]